Zac Efron is all beefed up and barely
recognizable on the set of his upcoming
flick the iron clock is Daddy not Zack
daddy or what is it yep that right there
is the actor showing off some serious
six-pack abs personally I count more
like 12 pack abs but I digress yeah
they're Zach's bulging biceps and his
deep bronze tan as he steps out of his
trailer in Louisiana wearing nothing but
a little blue towel and some slides oh
and check out that wig I was just
constantly training this is fans first
look at Zach's dramatic transformation
for the film which is based on the true
story of wrestling family the Von Erics
that was pretty intense shape but this
isn't the first time the High School
Musical alums transformed for a role I
mean now you're gonna have to beat me on
the big boys course princess
[Applause]
the actor recently opened up to Men's
Health about his 2017 film Baywatch
where he endured intense training and
man did its show last thing you want is
to show up after training that long and
look flat it's very vain of us but what
weren't they watching yeah and Zach
admitted that maintaining that beach bod
wasn't exactly realistic quote that
Baywatch look I don't know if that's
really attainable there's just too
little water in the skin like it's fake
it looks cgi'd and that required lasik's
powerful diuretics to achieve so I don't
need to do that I much prefer to have an
extra you know two to three percent body
fat everything's functional we trained
for the parts we for this movie in
particular we'd like
we wanted to achieve a look and that
required a specific type of training
Zach added that that strict regimen not
only took a toll on him physically but
mentally too quote I started to develop
insomnia and I fell into a pretty bad
depression for a long time something
about that experience burned me out I
had a really hard time re-centering
ultimately they chalked it up to taking
way too many diuretics for way too long
and it messed something up that was the
most extreme I'd ever gone and while
Zach didn't have to transform his body
for his most recent role in the greatest
beer run ever he opened up to E.T about
the challenge of telling the true story
of chicky Donahue a young vet who snuck
into the Vietnam War to deliver beer to
his friends who were serving in the
military
ah tricky I've run your beer you
shouldn't be here you think this is
funny back take me down the Journey of
transforming into chicky the stash the
accent I thought it was never gonna lose
that accent at the end of the movie I
was like oh this is never I'm gonna be
talking like this for a long time in New
York I was like thinking about these
interviews being like I'm gonna be able
to do an accident on it and it's it's
actually pretty hard there's uh but I
had a great uh dialect coach Jerome
Butler and he's fantastic he's the best
um yeah yeah and within it within like a
week we were something close to a pretty
specific accent the way Chickie's voice
is like iconic I don't know how to
describe it it's just the real jig the
real chicky yeah I could do that do what
bringing beer
foreign